un an après des équipes de dépollution
sont toujours au travail dans les zones
essentiellement rocheuses c'est ce que
nous allons voir sur l'île dedic qui se
situe au large du golfe du morbihan
les opérations de nettoyage laborieuse
dans des conditions difficiles qui vont
prendre encore des mois hélène pedeches
et philippe bouchet lendemain de tempête
heidi dans un vent assourdissant des
hommes en blanc traquer la moindre trace
de pétrole
un par un ils trient les galères
avant de les rendre à la crique la
position arrivait sur une zone où il y
avait que des galets et depuis le sablar
couvert toutes ces zones
donc au fur et à mesure l'on reprend les
zones qui se dé caisse naturellement
pour éviter
évidemment de d'enlever manuellement
donc là on retraite une zone qui a déjà
été travaillé par les militaires il ya
en début d'été cette deuxième phase de
dépollution a démarré il ya deux mois
après les plages nettoyer dans l'urgence
pour accueillir quelques touristes c'est
au tour des zones rocheuses et des
criques de galets un travail long et
minutieux assurée par cinq pompiers du
plan polmar est une entreprise de
dépollution engagé par total en tout 30
percent
ici pas de tracteur ni même de voitures
tout se fait à la main c'est fatigant
tous les jours je me dans les cailloux
et puis s'il vend sur toulouse vont
aussi ses tweets en tout le temps tout
le temps donc ça tue le nettoyage
devrait durer jusqu'en juin au moins
pour passer tout l'hiver sur l'île les
des pollueurs sont logés dans ces
mobiles homes le soir au bout il
retrouve les îliens l'erika n'a pas
seulement marqué les côtes dans les
esprits aussi elle a laissé son
empreinte
quand il ya des gros temps comme ça
on est inquiet c'est sûr que tant que
les mesures au niveau de l'état seront
pas prises un peu plus strictes ça on ne
sera toujours présent et
là on y pense tous les jours on a des
gens qui nettoie quotidiennement ils
vivent avec nous
sa visite sur l'île on est 80 en face à
100 les enfants n'ont plus n'oublie pas
ses dessins date d'il y a quinze jours
malgré cela les écoliers préfère retenir
chaque signe d'espoir pour le mois
prochain sans enfant tout cela et ça tu
es content de revoir les mouettes
vendredi soir sur le port les dépôts
lueur repartent passer le week-end sur
le continent petit à petit et dick se
défait de sa ceinture noire en un an 730
tonnes de déchets mazoutés ont été
retirés